yeah so this week the work kicked in
this isn't going to be an especially
dynamic vlog because I'm really tired
this weed the work kicked in properly
basically I had two problems she's
chewing on Friday and I spent a lot of
time in the library in fact almost all
my time in the library so this week on a
day-by-day basis on Monday I had my
rehearsals my twin man she's there my
meditation class but I also went to
formal at Worcester College now the nice
thing about what one of the nice things
about to having local colleges that you
can do that kind of thing you do what's
called formal swaps so I invite my
friends over exclusive Peters last year
for a formal home and then I went over
to Worcester on a Tuesday night which
was really nice apartment they have a
mission and star chef on on Wednesdays
but because it was Tuesday forget that
but the food was very nice it was nice
to catch up with the book with my mate
nothing to have any interesting happened
on Wednesday and on Thursday it was
almost like a microcosm of life here
generally because on Thursday I had my
first tutorial I had a tutorial on the
vacation work that was set in
atmospheric physics which is a bit
different than all because in the
undergraduate that a part of my degree
which is to say the first three years
you enhance shooters with people from
your college so I only had two tours
with either one of the perceptions of
Peters or all of us together or
individually but now for atmospheric
physics I think there was six or seven
of us all from different colleges or
doing the option so that was been
different and the feel of the transfers
been different was now in a half line it
was if it was in class four after the
new tutorial but that's the first one
under the belt sort of into the swing of
things now then we had a physics society
talk which was possibly the most
interesting talk I've ever been to
it was where I got called Julian Barbour
and it was called as time exists and
normally when it comes to these kind of
dogs we get 20 to 30 people maybe
telling
this time I had a full lecture theatre
it was unbelievably popular and when we
flipped the food out for nibbles
afterwards it was it wasn't pretty
because there was just like a stampede
of people but people enjoyed themselves
it was very very interesting talk if
he's written books about this kind of
thing actually I think I'm gonna go and
read something because if they're
anything like the talk you gave that
there will be extremely interesting
then I because I had to Bronwyn she's
doing on Friday
I decided basically to just stay up on
Thursday as late as I needed to to make
sure everything was ready yeah I did I
think I left the library at half three
and I sort of settled in for the night
I've got like food supplies and my
sainted dream kill that kind of stuff
and then my half of you know I decided
to sort of rank things on a thumbs-up
thumbs-down kind of system I don't know
II don't know if that was like getting
cabin fever if it was just me trying to
find an excuse not to native work but
yeah like Thursday involved an awful lot
of work but it also involved a lot of
the fun stuff that you do here and the
physics I took is these excellent
example of that then on Friday
Paula's post 10 if your Friday I was
still doing the old lighter Vanna wins
the gym and I had my University
Challenge sprouts those two together and
steadily I'm about two hours of sleep
well great but yeah I was on University
Challenge team for the college last year
and the other dear easily select 18 five
people for main team members the more
reserved who have put forward to the
University round so ox was only allowed
to put forward a certain number of
colleges and so the university challenge
like producers come to Oxford and do
another series of tests to determine
which college they want on and it's a
mixture of interview and aptitude as a
team but at this stage this is choosing
the college team so I had to do a 40
question round which was very difficult
and I know that logo through the second
round and I don't know who when that is
about that so now I'm going to be
keeping posted on because as the last
chance potentially for me to be on
University challenge and it's one of the
shows that I grew up watching I really
really want to be on it then on Saturday
I slept in very late because I was
recovering from my all nighter and then
went to see Skyfall with a bunch of
friends from college which was so good
if you have the opportunity to see it
because it is fantastic
then on Saturday evening I went to a
house party at a friend of mine who
graduated from college but still lives
in Oxford is working as another college
in their development office and that was
great I was dressed as a zombie and my
friends as always were incredibly
supportive of my YouTube efforts if you
put this on youtube this is so good
oh he's gonna kill me it also news I
asked my college to buy in a copy of the
theoretical options sort of major
recommended textbook I think given the
width of it of quantum field theory a
coconut might be more appropriate and
they bought it within two weeks there
was two copies in the college library so
just wow house you're gonna get that
come on
but on the last video and I think the
video before that couple of people asked
some questions so I thought I would go
through them now do I have a job and is
it something that other people in Oxford
do no the only work which you can
realistically expect to be able to get
in Oxford is working at the college bar
which pays well it's something like
seven quid an hour and I think they're
three hour shifts no four hour shifts
the bars open for minus seven till
eleven so that people work at bar and
you can also get stipend if your file
manager of our treasurer other than that
people don't have jobs because you
cannot expect to keep up with the
workload here which is immense and do a
job at the same time and still be sane
nobody I know has a job in Perm time at
least what most people tend to do is
they'll do part-time work outside of a
uni term time when they get back home
a lots been lazy honest can I do a tour
of my accommodation well actually on the
college YouTube channel there is a video
which I'm going to try and put here yeah
here about accommodation in some pieces
which includes a room tour of a freshers
room I will am I going to give you a
tour of my room ok be bothered
it is very messy right now you've got
managed to frame this video I think so I
avoided the worst of the mess but it is
really messy right now maybe next week
somebody also asked then they deleted
their comment subsequently about formal
dress in Oxford now what we call sub
fuss
you know I don't know what that stands
for oh but good to Google sacrifice
comes from the latin for all the dark
slash dusty color basically it's full
academic rest so in the study pictured
me here that's basically a dark suit so
either dark navy or black white shirt
white bow tie down and mortar board is
carried you do not wear your portable
that is a very bad luck and until you
graduate you know the when it comes to
events like formal hall well what we do
some peters at least is you just wear
something reasonably sharp and then you
go on top of it and when I went to
Worcester on Tuesday night very wear
suits with gals but not full subtask sup
fuscus warm for exams so support for
when you matriculate and other really
big new occasions and I can't think of
right I'm gonna edit this together I'll
see you next week